[Musik]
die Regierung reagiert heute gab
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
bekannt das Gaslieferant uniper
verstaatlich wird kostenpunkt 15
Milliarden Euro weitere systemrelevante
Betriebe könnten folgen rettet das die
deutsche Wirtschaft die Opposition hat
er ihre Zweifel und außerdem immer mehr
Flüchtlinge kommen nach Deutschland auch
über das Mittelmeer können wir uns das
leisten das möchte ich heute mit meinen
Gästen besprechen ex-afd-chefin und
Chemikerin Frauke Petry sie sagt
bestellt wie gewählt und jetzt das böse
Erwachen grüne Vision werden wahr
bildchefredakteur und tv-chef Klaus
Strunz sieht eine flüchtlingskrise 2.0
auf uns zu rollen auch mit von der
Partie die ehemaligen grünen Politikerin
und Energieexpertin Antje Hermenau sie
ist sich sicher es gibt kaum Alternative
zum russischen Gas der Landesvorsitzende
CDU Hamburg und Bundestagsabgeordnete
Christoph Ploss fordert die Verlängerung
der Kernkraft jede Kilowattstunde zählt
das ist sein Motto schön dass Sie alle
da sind es war ja eigentlich relativ
klar dass mit den Grünen in der
Regierung Atomkraft nicht angesagt sein
wird und mancher Wähler bereut jetzt gar
den Grünen seine Stimme gegeben zu haben
Frauke Petry überrascht das nicht und
ihr Thema heute Abend ist die grüne
götterdämmerung
eigentlich bekommen die Wähler oder
Deutschland gerade das nicht nur was sie
dieses Mal gewählt haben sondern genau
genommen was sie über Legislaturen
gewählt haben denn wenn man sagt grüne
Politik ist überall dann kann man
tatsächlich feststellen dass alle
Parteien auch allen voran die CDU ihre
Partei Herr bloß über Jahre über
Legislaturen die Politik gemacht haben
die die Grünen jetzt auch faktisch
wieder an die Macht gebracht hat der
Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft die
Verdammung der Kohleenergie vieles
andere mehr das Märchen von der Energie
Verknappung als neuer Religion ist
nichts kurzfristiges sondern über
Jahrzehnte angelegt gewesen und ein
bisschen auch die deutsche
Gutgläubigkeit und vielleicht sogar die
gut gemeinte Absicht alles richtig zu
machen und vor allen Dingen alles
richtiger als alle anderen Nationen und
genau daran drohen wir jetzt zu
scheitern nicht nur im eigenen Land
sondern durch den europäischen Verbund
reißen wir auch die Nachbarstaaten in
Europa mit ins energetische Unglück und
treffen wird es wie immer die
Mittelschicht und die Ärmsten der
Gesellschaft all diejenigen die heute
eher ein auch selbst erwirtschaften
können und möglicherweise in den
nächsten Jahren von staatlichen
transfersampeln abhängig sein werden
denn ein 300 Euro Zuschuss wird nicht
reichen wenn die Energierechnung die
Gasrechnung die Stromrechnung pro Monat
um mehrere hundert Euro steigt und
deswegen ist das eigentlich ein Desaster
und ich kann nur hoffen dass viele der
Bürger die aus gutem Willen grüne
gewählt haben jetzt merken dass diese
Art von Politik in die absolute
Mangelwirtschaft führt und dazu kann ich
nur sagen als gelernter DDR-Bürger
Mangelwirtschaft kennen von den rund 80
Millionen Deutschen bisher maximal 16
Millionen auch vielleicht die jungen
Leute gar nicht mehr ich finde nicht
dass es ein Ziel sein sollte das weitere
60 oder 56 Millionen diese Art von
Mangelwirtschaft kennenlernen sie trifft
auch dann das fragen wir da einmal Frau
Hermenau sie als ex-grüner ist der
Vorwurf zu hart oder angebracht dass wir
mit den Grünen die Mangelwirtschaft
kennenlernen werden wir werden die
wangenwirtschaft kennenlernen und das
hat auch was mit der Ansage zu tun dass
wir uns bescheidener verhalten sollen
das wurde ja ein narrativ gekleidet das
finde ich sehr defensiv wir sind
eigentlich eine Industrienation und
nicht so ein kleiner Farmer Stream ne
sondern wir wollen eigentlich vorne
mitspielen das tun wir übrigens auch
wenn man sich die Zahlen vor Corona mal
anguckt gab es nur drei Länder auf der
Welt die insgesamt überhaupt eine Lage
waren für mehr als 1000 Milliarden
US-Dollar
Dienstleistungen und Güter zu
exportieren China die USA und
Deutschland also England und Frankreich
müssen schon zusammenlegen im Export um
auf deutsche Größen zu kommen und das
riskieren wir gerade ganz massiv ich
verstehe nicht wie man
umverteilungsträume haben kann egal ob
in die soziale Schiene oder in die
ökologische Schiene wenn man kein Geld
erwirtschaftet ist unklar
Herr Ploss da kann man jetzt mal fragen
es ist jetzt nicht so als hätten nur SPD
und FDP mit den Grünen sympathisiert in
der Union haben ja auch einige mit
Schwarz-Grün vor der Wahl geliebäugelt
wer das denn jetzt noch eine Option für
Sie also ich wäre erst mal kurz zu dem
was sagen was Frau Petry immer erwähnt
hat ne und was bei ihm ja auch
durchschimmerte die Union ist schuld und
ein bisschen
die Frage zu beantworten jetzt kommt
erstmal
nein will gar nicht ein großes
Werbeblock einführen ich will auch sagen
natürlich hätte man mit dem Wissen von
heute früher auch einiges anders machen
müssen und natürlich sind auch
Entscheidungen die vor einigen Jahren
getroffen wurden aus heutiger Sicht
falsch man muss nur auch sagen im
Nachhinein ist man immer klüger und
spätestens nach dem 24 Februar dem
Angriffskrieg von Russland auf die
Ukraine hätte man Umsteuern müssen und
sagen müssen die Energiepolitik
Deutschlands die kann nicht mehr auf Gas
basieren und es müssen Alternativen her
neben den erneuerbaren und da glaube ich
nicht das Kernkraft eine wichtige Rolle
spielen wird aber bloß vielleicht darf
ich da kurz dazwischen gehen denn
tatsächlich ich verstehe dass sie als
CDU Politiker ihre Partei verteidigen
aber das ist so wie 2015 bei der
flüchtlingskrise zu sagen das war
Naturereignis wir konnten das vorher
nicht wissen und das was jetzt gerade
mit der Energiepolitik passiert ist ein
ist ein Scheitern Verzeihung mit Ansage
wir wissen seit langer Zeit dass uns die
erneuerbaren Energien keine Grundlast
bringen dass wir am Ende uns von Putin
abhängig machen konnte man sehen wenn
man die Menge russischen Gases mal sich
ansah die wir von dort exportieren und
im Nachhinein nein
so wahrgenommen dass sie sich immer von
Russland abkoppeln wollte und das mal
etwas ich rede mit Energiepolitik der
letzten Legislatur und da müssen wir
feststellen dass Merkel ja auch gegen
den Willen der Parteien Fragezeichen
nur um da die FDP nicht rauszulassen es
waren FDP Politiker der Mitte der 90er
Jahre den
auf nach 5 D-Mark polite Benzin in die
Welt gesetzt hat es wird über den grünen
zugeschrieben die waren tatsächlich
damit beteiligt und haben es beschlossen
aber es waren FDP-Politiker und zwar der
Chef des Umweltbundesamtes der 21 Jahre
diese Behörde geleitet hat der hat diese
Forderung in Gang und zwar warum um die
Autofahrer dazu zu bewegen das Auto
stehen zu lassen und das ist glaube ich
was das größte deutsche Problem wir
versuchen ständig als Politiker die
Bürger zu erziehen aber das ist gar
nicht unsere Aufgabe
hat widersprechen weil weil sie sie
haben ja sie haben früher ja auch
Verantwortung getragen auch in der AFD
und die AFD war immer die Partei in
Deutschland bis heute die eine ganz ganz
enge Beziehung zu Russland gesucht aber
reden
wollen
und die bis heute sagt es sollen
gasbeziehung mit Putin Russland geben
also gerade die hat ja nicht
rausgelassen
aber sie haben damals ja auch nicht
gesagt also die energiebeziehung in
Russland soll abgebrochen werden
wir bleiben einmal bei der
Energiepolitik und da würde ich dich
gerne Fragen Klaus es kam mir jetzt
gerade so rüber als wäre erst durch den
Angriffskrieg der Ukraine klar geworden
das was falsch von diesem Land läuft
energiepolitisch ist es dir da auch erst
klar geworden also ich werde mir das
jetzt angehört und so und wenn nicht
alles so traurig wären wenn wir nicht
wirklich voll in der Tinte sitzen würden
und wenn nicht Leute von pleite und
soziale Armut bedroht werden dann müsste
man eigentlich schmunzeln über alles
weil wir werden ja Zeuge eines
großangelegten sozialexperiments ich
glaube viele Wähler der Grünen wollten
gar nicht die Grünen wählen sondern die
wollten nur dass ich mal was ändert dass
man dieses großkoalitionäre Zeug zu Ende
ist und eigentlich fanden sie die Ideen
mit dem Lastenfahrrad und so auch ganz
niedlich und dann hat man gedacht jetzt
probieren wir es mal so das finde ich
erstmal okay klar muss jedem
verständigen Menschen gewesen sein dass
das der Einstieg in den Umbau einer
Gesellschaft ist denn wir haben ja jetzt
eine linke Regierung die ist nicht ganz
doll links aber sie ist links und sie
hat einen kleinen gelben Wicht kann auf
der Kasse sitzen mit dem Christian
Lindner als Finanzminister der sich
jeden Tag überlegen muss ob er den
Scheiß mitmacht und dann weiter an der
Macht bleibt oder irgendwann mal sagt
ich mache nicht mehr mit und alles in
die luftjagd da besteht da halt morgens
auf schaut sich den Spiegel und sagt gar
nicht so schlecht Minister zu sein und
dann macht das wieder mit ja und das ist
die Situation die ist aber nicht vom
Himmel gefallen um auf deine Frage zu
kommen sondern das konnte jedes haben
wir in diesem Studio haben wir das
beschrieben wir haben es diskutiert und
geschrieben dann sind wir angegriffen
worden als zukunftsverweigerer als
retrotypen als sonst irgendwas und jetzt
ist es halt so gekommen jetzt muss man
sagen Belag pech für die Grünen und die
SPD das jetzt so viele Krisen auf einmal
kommen bei denen sie in jeder einzelnen
versagen weil sie den falschen
politischen Kompass als Grundlage haben
nämlich ein sie haben es angedeutet der
Staat muss alles richten und man muss
die Menschen umziehen wir reden ja jetzt
noch gar nicht darüber dass da auch
eingepreist ist wie man sich benehmen
soll was man sagen soll dass man
Duschen soll jetzt der neueste Knüller
man soll also nur noch auf Sound zu viel
Quadratmetern wohnen und wenn man Kinder
hat dann kann man eine größere Wohnung
nehmen oder oder bauen aber dann soll
man gleich sozusagen zwei Türen einbauen
damit du die Kinder aus dem Haus sind
bloß nicht so viel Wohnraum hat die die
Baumeisterin hat solche lustigen Träume
aber das ist alles nicht von heute auf
morgen geboren wann das stand immer
überall und es war klar wenn das
Rot-Grün wird mit ein bisschen gelb oder
gar nur rot grün dann kommt das alles
und ich glaube auch dass man da so
schnell nicht mehr rauskommt insofern
sind diejenigen die das mal so als
Versuch in ihren Prenzlauer Berg und
München Grünwald Wohnungen mal so mit
überlegt haben das könnte man doch mal
so machen und so denn die sind jetzt
mit Täter eines Umbaus einer eines
großen gesellschaftlichen Umbaus und die
CDU und ist auch noch zu sagen hat sich
natürlich in den Jahren zuvor in den
großen Fragen um die es geht auch nicht
mit Rum bekleckern Migrationspolitik
sprechen wir später drüber
Energiepolitik das haben wir schon
natürlich alles richtig gelaufen ist
vielleicht können für die nächsten
Wochen und Monate die Leute haben einen
scheiß Angst
macht Bling Bling Bling Bling so komisch
ja wir wissen die Kuchen einladen ich
habe gesehen drei Stück Kuchen noch
einen anderen dazu drei Stück gucken
7,50 ich habe es gelassen ich sage es in
Ordnung komm her kriegsen Kaffee so ist
die Lage also die Leute haben eine
furchtbare Angst dass sie in ein paar
Wochen schon nicht mehr in der Lage sein
werden ihren normalen Alltag zu
finanzieren den sie gewohnt sind wir
reden darüber dass ich Strom und
Gaspreise das wird sich noch eine Weile
hinziehen das ist ein streckbetrieb zur
Sache in der Preisentwicklung aber da
kommt dass die steigen zwei Drittel der
Inflation die in die jetzt vor der
Haustür stehen und zweistellig werden
wird sind über die Energiepreise ein
Drittel sind andere Geschichten denke
ich so ungefähr eine Größenordnung das
Problem ist wir haben also vor dieser
Energiekrise in der übrigens nur europa
steckt kein anderer Kontinent nur Europa
hat dieses Problem
das hat auch viel mit dem mit der Vorhut
wir sind die Besten wir zeigen dass die
Deutschen wiederum in Europa noch ganz
besonders viel von diesen Problemen
abbekommen
diese Probleme nicht wir haben das
Problem das treibt die Preise nach oben
wir sind die armen Schweine die teuer
bezahlen müssen für das was sie wollen
wir haben aus der Pipeline das Gas zur
Hälfte billiger sage ich mal ungefähr
als das LMG dass dann irgendwann mal aus
Amerika mit Schweröl betriebenen großen
Tanger rüber geschippert wird ökologisch
angesagt dazu kommen wir später
wir haben früher für sag ich mal eine
Megawattstunde Strom haben wir
vielleicht so um die 50 bis 60 € bezahlt
wir sind jetzt in einer Preisrange von
200 bis 300 Euro sag mal 250 € pro
Megawattstunde und das bleibt die
nächsten Jahre so weil wir keine
Infrastruktur haben um irgendwas zu
ändern wir müssen eigentlich mit jedem
dämlichen Dynamo den wir irgendwo haben
jedes Kraftwerk alles was wir haben
selber Strom produzieren hier in
Deutschland selbst produzieren und
Zustande Peter damit wir der Lage sind
die Preise zu senken diese verfünfferung
der Preise können weder Mittelstand noch
die Bürger ertragen es wird nicht
funktionieren Herr plössert dazu auch
heute seine These mitgebracht was zu tun
ist jetzt in der Bundesregierung wir
stehen vor allem der härtesten Winter in
den vergangenen Jahrzehnten Robert
Habeck hat selber eingeräumt jede
Kilowattstunde zählt und das kann man
nur unterstützen allerdings
unterscheidet sich diese Aussage vom
Handeln der Ampelkoalition denn mitten
in diesem Herbst und vor dem härtesten
Winter seit vielen vielen Jahren möchte
die Ampelkoalition die Kernkraftwerke in
Deutschland abschalten das ist
unverantwortlich und wird dazu führen
dass die Strom- und Energiepreise weiter
steigen daher mein Plädoyer Herr Habeck
herr Scholz stoppen Sie diesen Irrsinn
verlängern Sie die Laufzeiten der
Kernkraftwerke
schon längst geplant ist eigentlich
innerhalb der Partei und jetzt einfach
noch die Wahl in Niedersachsen
abgewartet wird sie wissen ja auch wie
meintestiert in Parteien kann es sein
dass es eigentlich schon längst das ist
eine sehr sehr gute Frage und es gibt
tatsächlich auch in Berliner
Regierungsviertel bei vielen
mittlerweile die Vermutung dass die
Grünen die Niedersachsen war noch
abwarten wollen weil die grüne Basis ja
gegen die Verlängerung der Laufzeiten
der Kernkraftwerke ist das halte ich
wirklich für unverantwortlich weil wir
brauchen jetzt die Entscheidung wir
brauchen jetzt Planungssicherheit das
würde dazu führen dass die Strompreise
erst einmal sinken würden weil einfach
das Angebot wieder vergrößert werden
würde und deswegen kann man die
Niedersachsen Wahl nicht abwarten wenn
Herr Habeck so denkt dann macht er das
Gegenteil dessen was er immer im
Wahlkampf versprochen hat klar ist das
ein Grund warum vielleicht auch Menschen
das Vertrauen in die Politik verlieren
ich muss sagen ich als Bürgerin finde
das schon sehr bedenklich naja ja glaube
ich auch aber man kann das Argument ja
auch einmal umdre was bleibt von den
Grünen denn wenn sie Waffen liefern und
Atomkraft weiterlaufen lassen sozusagen
wenig und
das ist ja
haben sie recht ist bisschen problemig
aber ja stimmt ich meine das aber
durchaus ganz ernst wann kommt
eigentlich für Politiker der Moment wo
man sagt jetzt bin ich so weit von dem
Weg dessen wegen ich bevor ich in eine
Regierung kam Politik gemacht habe das
jetzt auch mal Schluss ist und das
glaube ich macht es habe so schwer und
dem grünen so schwer auch das letzte
Gründungsmythos Teilchen nämlich die
Kernkraft oder die Gegnerschaft zur
Kernkraft aus der Hand zu geben in der
Sache selber finde ich ja das habe ich
schon Argument das hilft zu wenig
deswegen mache ich es ganz weg
finde ich skurril
aber das ist auch wieder das ist also
erstens ist das der widersprühen sich
und dann muss man sich immer vorstellen
das ist wieder so ein typischer
Politiker kopfgeschwurbel Dings denn
wenn ich jetzt sagen wir mal drei Kinder
habe und habe aber nur
etwas zu essen dann lasse ich ja das
Essen nicht weg und dann sind alle tot
also ich meine es ist eine völlig
skurrile Logik sondern man wird ja dann
versuchen das so aufzuteilen in meinem
Beispiel oder wenigstens eins
durchzubringen also nutzt ja das weniger
was man hat
das könnte man sagen das Beispiel ist
wegen Leben und Tod ein bisschen
übertrieben ich finde aber dass wir in
einer Phase sind wo wir viele Themen
haben die am Ende des Tages was
vielleicht nicht mit 10 Millionen haben
10 Millionen Haushalte können mit Strom
versorgt werden wenn diese weiterlaufen
den Bürgern nur schwer erklären kann
aber was ja jeder weiß der diesen
Berliner Politikbetrieb kennengelernt
hat und wir sitzen ja drei am Tisch
Politiker in Parteien ticken anders Herr
Habig weiß ganz genau die Niedersachsen
war es entscheidend für das Überleben
seiner Partei mindestens kurzfristig und
deswegen ist völlig irrelevant was ein
Bürger denkt was die Wirtschaft denkt es
ist nur wichtig was die Partei denkt das
ist für einen normalen Menschen der sich
für Parteien nur bedingt interessiert
weil er nur ein bis zwei Prozent der
Deutschen überhaupt irgendwie in der
Partei organisiert sind völlig undenkbar
und deswegen glaube ich haben viele
Bürger ein Riesenproblem überhaupt zu
verstehen wie dieses politikertheater in
Berlin funktioniert aber da würde ich
sagen jetzt sind wir doch wirklich in
der Zeit wo mit diesem Teil der Schluss
sein muss da habe ich ja noch ein
Gewissen quasi feltonistischen Respekt
vor dem dass das so ist wenn man wenn es
wurscht ist ob ich im Oktober entscheide
oder nächsten April jetzt geht's aber
darum dass die die Leute verarmen das
sozusagen die Leute frieren das
muss man doch mal endlich sagen und wir
machen das jetzt so egal ja also wir
hatten ja die 90er Jahre wo fast 80% der
Leute ihren Arbeitsplatz wechseln
mussten weil das alles weg ist wir haben
die Idee und Sozialisierung erlebt und
in meinem also auf jeden Fall der Punkt
an der Sache ist es gab sehr viele
also es gab sehr viele Suizide es gab
sehr viele Menschen die in einen
fleckmark Gefallen sind oder in einen
eine tiefe starre gefallen sind es gab
verdrängungswettbewerbe bei den
Arbeitsplätzen ja neu entstanden sind
die Männer haben sie bekommen damit sie
nicht Unruhen veranstalten die Frauen
guckten in die Röhre also wir haben sehr
viele Erfahrungen gesammelt was es für
eine Bevölkerung bedeutet wenn in einem
Industrieland eine demozialisierung
stattfindet egal wie aus welchen
Ursachen und deswegen glaube ich dass
wir gut beraten sind sehr schnell neue
Sicherheit und die Bevölkerung
reinzubringen und auch nach außen
auszustrahlen wir brauchen die außer
nicht Investoren gerade wenn man viel
vor hat ich habe Sorge dass die
Energiewende so wie Sie vielleicht mal
funktionieren könnte wenn man denn in
allen Bereichen eine gewisse
technologische Tiefe erreichen würde
Speicherung Batterie zum Beispiel dass
das eine gute Sache sein könnte und dass
die Mehrheit der Schwerpunkt das
eigentlich auch will aber sie will es
nicht um den Preis der eigenen Existenz
und wenn man jetzt als Partei nicht die
Größe hat oder als Regierung und sagt
die Realitäten haben sich total geändert
wir stehen vor völlig neuen Realitäten
unsere Parteiprogramm ist keine Bibel
sondern wir sind in der Lage die neuen
Realitäten anzuerkennen und wir
überwenden das jetzt um wir machen das
anders wir sehen ja auch schon dass die
Bürger unzufrieden sind auch Angst haben
also in Thüringen zum Beispiel Frau
Petry kriegen jetzt schon linke und AFD
dann zusammen 49 Prozent macht auch eine
Mehrheit ja macht ihnen das Angst also
wenn man die Umfragen sieht na ich
glaube was was viele Politiker in Berlin
und auch in anderen Landesregierungen in
den Bundesländern unterschätzen ist dass
der Prozess einer Radikalisierung der
Ränder noch lange nicht abgeschlossen
ist und so wie wie die Fundis bei den
Grünen Radikalen und zum Teil
extremistisch sind sind es bei der AFD
ja auch und diese Ränder berühren sich
und Leute die sehen dass sie in der
Mitte keine Vertretung erfinden
gleichsetzen
Enden sich immer irgendwann berühren und
das Menschen die das Gefühl haben sie
finden in der Mitte nicht mehr statt
weil die Lebenswelt der Politiker von
ihrer eigenen einfach so wahnsinnig weit
entfernt ist die sind bereit sich zu
radikalisieren das kann man genau
genommen an der Sprache von Politikern
über Jahre sehr klar erkennen das ist
keine Theorie das ist das ist gängige
Praxis und deswegen ich glaube der der
Weimarer Vergleich ist zwar auf eine
Weise ausgelutscht und die Leute wollen
ihn nicht mehr hören aber genau genommen
ist eine derartige Radikalisierung und
eine Wiederholung der Geschichte egal zu
welcher radikalen Figur hin immer wieder
möglich und das wird meiner Ansicht nach
von den großen Parteien völlig
überschätzt und ich kann mir haben sie
Angst vor erschlagen ihre exportal ich
bin ich bin kein ich bin kein
ängstlicher Mensch weil ich glaube noch
gibt es Zeit etwas zu tun aber dafür
müssten sich links und rechts der
demokratischen Mitte außerhalb der
Ränder müssten sich Gruppen müssten sich
Parteien müssten sich Persönlichkeiten
vor allen Dingen finden die sagen es ist
Schluss wir reden Klartext weil das was
Herr Habig gemacht hat den Bäcker zu
erklären dass sie gar keine Brötchen
mehr backen müssen und trotzdem ich
pleite gehen das ist ja so erkennbar
bullshits Motivation der eigenen Partei
zu geben nein da bin ich raus gut
verstehen dann ich glaube was für
einigen brauchen sind Leute aus dem
realen Leben aus der Wirtschaft wir
haben eine Bundesregierung und die
letzten für die letzte gilt das glaube
ich auch
gar nicht Beispiel keiner suchen Sie ein
min
isterwirtschaft gearbeitet hat ich rede
nicht für Unternehmer da hat von denen
wahrscheinlich keiner jemals in der
Fabrikhalle gestanden und das ist genau
diese Art von Politik sehen wir aber
eben nicht erst jetzt sondern schon seit
geraten Zusammenhänge werden nicht
erkannt das stimmt in der Tat also zum
Beispiel ist die Frage mit dem AdBlue
das Bundesminister
Wirtschaftsministerium sagt na gut wenn
sie es nicht produzieren wollen weil in
die Energiekosten zu hoch sind dann
lassen Sie es halt und Sie können ja die
Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen sondern willst
aber nicht verschulden Sachsen-Anhalt
und und ansonsten können Sie Produktion
der stilllegen dann gehen halt ihre
Mitarbeiter in Kurzarbeit ja okay dann
wird also
das ist damit hinten da dann nicht so
viel Dreck rauskommt so ähm das ist ein
tolles Zeug das AdBlue funktioniert also
endkarbonisierung geht in vielen oder
Entgiftung von Sachen geht in vielen
Bereichen aber jetzt muss es eben
importiert werden sagt das Ministerium
auch dann können wir ja in Porto machen
damit zerstören wir die eigene
mittelständische Industrie das geht
nicht aus meiner Sicht wir werden
überall abhängig von Importen wir sollen
weil bei Solar Sonne auf große hurra
rufe ausschreien aber wenn wir bat
zusammenrechnen die ganze Stoffe die wir
da brauchen und verbauen müssen kriegen
wir aus China China ist natürlich ein
lupenbreite Demokratie und gegen Putins
Russland gar nicht zu vergleichen was
sind das für ein Affentheater es ist
alles
anrüchigigen können zurzeit in den
letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten insbesondere
der Regierungszeit von Frau Merkel ist
uns ja quasi eingeredet worden und wir
haben es alle mehr oder weniger billigen
Kauf genommen dass alle Fragen der
Wirtschaft und der Zukunft nur im
Zusammenspiel aller Länder gelöst werden
können also man kann im Grunde nur noch
im großen Verbund alles lösen das war ja
das große Mantra und das ist wenn die
Sonne scheint echt hübsch dann
verabreden Sie mit dem irgendwas Schönes
der hält sich dran und dann verabredet
man mit dem was schönes am besten
verabreden die sich auch alle noch
untereinander und am Schluss sind alle
glücklich das ist so richtig schönes ist
Kuschel kuschelbällebad dass wir uns da
vorgestellt haben aber dieses dieses
System
übersteht den Stresstest jetzt nicht
weil es nämlich besser man könnte Sachen
selber also die bezahlste Sache ist ja
die gasherstellung wo wir also sozusagen
aus ideologischen Gründen gegen Fracking
sind und uns das Zeug dann aus Kanada
oder irgendwoher herliefern lassen also
die können es machen wir machen es nicht
da würde ich doch mal sagen wenn wir da
und zwar in die moderne Form des
Trackings investiert hätten oder würden
dann hätten wir etwas was wir selber
machen und in dem Moment wo ich es
ausspreche sitzen da draußen Menschen
und sagen naja das ist aber nationaler
ein sehr nationaler Zugang zu allem
genau weil wenn man sich nämlich für
sich selber sorgt dann ist man in Krisen
nicht von anderen abhängig und wenn man
zu viel von anderen abhängig ist dann
geht es möglicherweise schlecht ein
Punkt also ich glaube tatsächlich auch
unsere Mentalität muss sich ändern es
kann nicht sein dass wir sagen
wir wollen Tracking Gas wir wollen
Tracking Gas aus den USA aber machen uns
in Deutschland die Hände nicht schmutzig
da glaube ich
da will ich einmal massiv widersprechen
natürlich muss man gucken dass man sich
nicht von einem Land abhängig macht und
das sicherlich mit Blick auf Russland
sehr viel falsch gelaufen aber gerade
die deutsche Wirtschaft profitiert doch
massiv davon dass sie in viele Länder
investieren kann und in viele Länder
ihre Produkte verkaufen kann
vielleicht ich habe eben auch zugehört
wir gerade die deutschen Autobauer viele
Mittelständler die dran denken die
profitieren doch massiv davon dass die
Produkte in den USA und vor allem in
China verkauft werden können wenn wir
jetzt sagen wir wickeln das alles ab und
jedes Land soll nur noch Produkte
herstellen die es in ihrem eigenen Land
ja
ein massiven Wohlstandsverlust erleiden
einmal kurz einmal aussprechen worauf
wir nur viel stärker achten müssen in
Zukunft und das ist die Lehre aus der
aktuellen Situation dass wir uns breiter
aufstellen und uns nicht von einem Land
zu abhängig machen wie das in
Energiebereich von Russland
aber ich kann sie haben durchaus einen
richtigen Gedanken aber genau genommen
ist das was wir seit Jahrzehnten machen
und im Grunde genommen müssten heute
Abend auch den Euro diskutieren weil der
nämlich ein Grundübel bei der ganzen
Angelegenheit ist seit viel zu langer
Zeit genau genommen sind wir sehr
wahllos gewesen in der Wahl unserer
Partner denn das Thema China dass er
seit den 90er Jahren eine große Rolle
spielt wo ganz viele deutsche Firmen in
der Hoffnung auf billige Arbeitskräfte
und große Margen ihre Arbeitsplätze hin
verlagert haben aber eben nicht nur ihre
Arbeitsplätze sondern vor allen Dingen
das Know-how des Chinesen gern genommen
haben um es dann zu kopieren aus
chinesischer sich genau das richtige hat
er dazu geführt dass wir uns Schritt für
Schritt unsere eigenen Unabhängigkeit
die wir gehabt haben beraubt haben doch
dazu kommt dass wir uns als EU gegen
China nun abschotten müssen damit China
nicht mit der Billig-Konkurrenz den
europäischen Markt kaputt macht wir sind
im Grunde steht hinter der der
Russlandkrise
die nächste schon längst an
dass das Thema China und China ist
Vormachtstellung in allen Teilen der
Welt könnte längst erkannt werden und
wir reden immer davon dass wir China
nicht kritisch gegenüberstehen dürfen
tatsächlich glaube ich dass wenn wir als
freie Welt uns von Diktatur und
unabhängiger machen wollen es geht nie
um alles oder nichts aber unabhängige
dann brauchen wir mit China z.B eine
Strategie der Verhandlung auf Augenhöhe
so so wie so wie ich so wie China ganz
klare Regeln für Investitionen im
Ausland stellt und damit seine eigene
Format Position in den Unternehmen
Sicherheit hätte Europa das auch machen
können ist aber am Ende nicht passiert
so haben wir am Ende Know-how hingegeben
und es gibt ganz viele solche
Gründen es gibt ganz viele Beispiele das
heißt wir könnten wir müssen aus den
Fehlern mit Russland und China lernen
aber
wir starten gerade wieder das Knie nicht
auf die Stange ob das auf Stange auf das
Russland Problem und sehen ganz es ist
China bleiben einmal beim Russland
Problem bei der Frau Hermenau plädieren
sie ja eigentlich für etwas Pragmatismus
ja unbedingt also ich habe nicht
verstanden warum wir keine
Außenministerin mehr haben aber eine
kriegsministerin die ständig davon
spricht dass man den Putin vernichten
muss als ob der da alleine stünde das
ist die ganze Nomenklatura und da gab es
auch immer ein Teil der sagte lass uns
nach Asien gehen die Europäer haben
einander Waffel also das muss man glaube
ich mal so festhalten das wird nur
landläufig nicht erwähnt das darf keiner
sagen ich komme bestimmt morgen auch
wieder auf dem Twitter Index aber egal
der Punkt auf den ich hinausführt ist
eigentlich folgender wir haben uns
glaube ich in der Frage voran weil
natürlich auch gerne festhalten wollen
an unserer Vorstellung aus dem letzten
Jahrhundert von einer liberalen Welt und
diese liberale Welt die ist schön eine
grüne Wiese mit Blumen alles super die
die Hummeln und die Bienen brummen alles
super aber der Punkt an der Sache ist
das ganz woanders dieser Reichtum
hergestellt wird wir haben das immer
ausgeblendet wir sind erstens auf den
angewiesen fast 50 Prozent unserer
staatlichen Einnahmen es kommen über
Exporte und angegliederte
Dienstleistungen die Autobranche haben
wir ruiniert die ist längst weg die ist
gar nicht mehr da das Bisschen was noch
da ist möchte E-Mobility machen bei den
Strompreisentwicklung die ist skizziert
habe können Sie das der Pfeife rauchen
Milliarden Gewinne gemacht
alles sehen die Entlassungen Ingolstadt
am stattgefunden also sie wollen dass
wir mit Putin reden um ihre These
zusammenzufassen wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr können weil wir gar nicht
mehr die Power dafür haben also wir
waren immer schon so ein bisschen der
Affen Felsen auf Gibraltar als Europäer
so auch für die Amerikaner die fanden
das immer alles sehr unübersichtlich
werde hat er eigentlich was zu sagen die
deutschen den wurde jetzt eingeflüstert
Mensch dann mach doch hier einfach
Situation und von Frau bärbock dass sie
also mir wurde schon reichen wenn sie
diplomatischer sprechen ich habe gar
keine großen Forderungen ich möchte
einfach nur nicht dass immer gleich von
Vernichtung und totalen Krieg gesprochen
wird das finde ich wirklich unangemessen
und ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
irgendwie so eine Schiene finden mit den
Russen zu verhandeln die haben jetzt im
jamalfeld schon angefangen
in vielen Fragen nicht unterstützt bei
der EURO Frage hat der versagt in meinen
Augen aber in der Frage unterstütze ich
ihn weil es gefährlich ist die Russen
werden da sein immer auch noch in den
nächsten 10 und 20 Jahren machen was sie
wollen ein Völkerrecht das haben sie
auch wenn man die Amerikaner sind die
Ansprechpartner der Russen das waren sie
immer wir kriegen einen neuen Kalten
Krieg wir kriegen eine Ost- und Westwelt
und die ostwelt wird irgendwo in der
Ukraine oder am Rand der Ukraine dann
ihre Grenze ziehen und so runtergehen
wir kriegen aber dann in der ostwelt ein
rohstoffkartell Europa ist nichts ohne
Rohstoffe und Energie das merken wir
doch gerade
also eine Frage habe ich schon also ich
verstehe grundsätzlich dass sie
Diplomatie fordern die Frage ist nur wir
haben uns ja nun selbst durch unsere
falschen Energiepolitik in eine Lage
reinmiert in der wenn ich Putin wäre
auch kein Grund sehe derzeit und so
weiter
also die ganzen Forderungen für auch
viele deutsche Gewerbetreibende
wirklich nachvollziehen kann macht
nordstream 2 aus sind ja völlig
realitätsfremd weil dadurch auch wenn
wir es aufmachen wollten kein russisches
gasfließen das stimmt nicht also andere
naja also ich würde gerne mal testen
aber
den Test politisch zu bezahlen also das
Risiko wird momentan
wenn wir hier über Lösungen sprechen
also vorher genau hat ihre Lösung
angeboten ihre Lösung wie soll es
aussehen nee Waffenlieferung
Wirtschaftssanktionen das Thema Ukraine
ja schon mehrfach und ich glaube dass am
Ende der Krieg militärisch entschieden
wird dass die Sanktionen in der Tat ähm
die westliche Welt mindestens wenn ich
härter treffen als die Russen und dass
die Russen noch eine Weile in der Lage
sind das durchzuhalten auch weil sie
ihre eigene Bevölkerung alles zumuten
werden das muss man auch sagen die
Russen haben überhaupt keine Achtung vor
dem Individuum so wie sie ihre Soldaten
vor die ukrainischen Kanonen schicken
als Kanonenfutter und sie dort ja
letztlich in ihr Unglück rennen lassen
wenn sie auch bereit ihre eigenen Leute
zu opfern habe ich auch insofern da muss
man sich gar keine Illusionen machen die
Russen haben damit ihr in ihren
eigenleuten keine Gnade ich sehe derzeit
nicht dass es ein Fenster für
Verhandlungen gibt weil Putin sich keine
Niederlage leisten kann er ist als
Mensch psychologisch so aufgestellt dass
er nicht verliert über Putin reden
wollen wir einmal reinhören was er
selber gesagt hat um auf dem aktuellen
Stand zu sein
ich möchte diejenigen die solche
Äußerungen über Russland machen daran
erinnern dass auch unser Land über
verschiedene zerstörungsmittel verfügt
und in einigen Fällen sind sie moderner
als die der NATO-Länder es ist kein
Bluff und diejenigen die versuchen uns
mit Atomwaffen zu erpressen sollten
wissen dass sich die Wetterfahne drehen
und auf sie zeigen kann
Klaus wie ernst muss man diese Warnung
nehmen vom Putin na ja ernster als mir
das jetzt im Moment innerhalb der
westlichen Staatengemeinschaft so
vorkommt jedenfalls in der
veröffentlichten Meinung ich finde und
zwar nicht weil er möglicherweise jetzt
zu einer großen Gegenoffensive mit ganz
vielen Panzern die dann irgendwie im
Schnee stecken bleiben oder sowas
ausholt sondern weil er ich folge dem
Gedanken von VP3 ein Mann ist der nicht
verlieren kann und ein Mann der nicht
verlieren wird und ein Mann der für sich
entscheidet wenn ich schon verliere und
untergehen nämlich noch ganz viele mit
wahrscheinlich das ist die Mentalität
und das macht mir heute schon Gänsehaut
ich glaube auch dass so eine
gänsehautwelle heute ein bisschen durch
Deutschland gegangen ist angesichts der
atomdrohung er ist ja nicht so dass der
jetzt da irgendwie Nebenraum geht und so
macht und dann ist Deutschland weg aber
die die die Sorge dass er als
zurückgedrängt da zu etwas zu einer
Verzweiflungstat ist glaube ich das Wort
greifen könnte die kann ich nicht ganz
ignorieren und gefolgt für mich aber
eine andere Logik als bei ihnen aus bei
mir folgt und auch aus bei ihnen weil
sie haben die ganze Zeit gesagt Putin
hat wahrscheinlich kein Interesse an
Verhandlungen ich bin nicht sicher ob
der Westen Interesse an Verhandlungen
mit Wladimir Putin haben sollte ich
glaube er kann nur in die Knie gezwungen
werden mit militärischer Kraft Olaf
Scholz hat heute noch mal daran erinnert
dass wir auf der Seite des Rechts stehen
und nicht auf der Seite der Gewalt dann
muss man aber Olaf Scholz dran erinnern
dass man manchmal Gewalt braucht um
Recht durchzusetzen und genau in diesem
Moment befinden wir uns jetzt und
Wirtschaftssanktionen der beispielsweise
bislang nicht erfolgreich also Gabor
Steingart beispielsweise der Bevölkerung
ins Kino
als Ansicht ich würde sagen das die
wirtschaftsaktionen in Russland
natürlich wirken aber sie machen nicht
sie haben nicht so viel impact nicht so
viel Auswirkung wegen der Mentalität die
gerade beschrieben worden ist also die
Leidensfähigkeit der Russen ist
natürlich viel viel größer als die
Leidensfähigkeit der deutschen die schon
quietschen wenn Sie die Heizung
runterdrehen müssen ja ich mache es
jetzt mal bewusst polemisch gegen uns
selbst aber ich glaube dass es Momente
gibt da gilt das diplomatische Gebot
dass man immer im Gespräch bleiben
können muss nicht doch und ich glaube er
aber dann das ist meine ich ja da habe
ich eine andere ich glaube dass dass das
mit dem Menschen Wladimir Putin mit dem
Präsidenten nicht funktionieren wird und
deshalb gibt es nur die Möglichkeit in
niederzuringen alles und am Ende vor
Gericht zu stellen wenn er dann noch am
Leben alles andere würde ja alles andere
würde ja auch bedeuten wenn wir uns in
meiner Weltpolitik umschauen das große
Nationen immer kleinere überfallen
können und dann gibt es den Ruf nach
Diplomatie weil man sagt naja wir können
die eh nicht bezwingen oder die werden
dann durchdrehen
[Gelächter]
guten Gründen irgendwann nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg etabliert dass alle
Staaten gleiche Rechte haben sollen und
das ist nicht ein Rechte stärkeren gibt
sondern eine Stärke des Rechts und wir
haben ja noch andere Fälle ich nenne nur
China und Taiwan die gucken ganz genau
hin die Chinesen was da passiert und
wenn die den Eindruck haben die
Weltgemeinschaft akzeptiert das was die
Russen da machen dann werden die sich
Taiwan holen und deswegen müssen wir
alles dafür tun damit ein Diktator wie
Putin geschockt wird
keine Muckis und das ist Moment die
Tatsachen die Russen fahren nur mit
Amerikanern und ihre Amerikaner haben
kein Interesse jetzt mal schnell zu
verhandeln das Problem bleibt in Europa
liegen wir Europäer sind aber diejenigen
auf dem Schulhof die sonst immer dran
sind bei der klassenkeile und jetzt
kriegen wir sie mal richtig weil wir
nämlich immer die Backen aufblasen weil
wir immer großer Werte vorantragen wie
eine Monstranz bei der Prozession aber
nicht normal Demokratie ist keine
schlechte demonstrieren mit Gewalt das
durchzusetzen was wir für richtig halten
und die Frage ist definitiv
groß ist denn die Angst jetzt vom
Atomkrieg also ich finde wir sind jetzt
schon sehr schnell wieder vom Park okay
für mich wirklich sehr beängstigend
worden weggerückt muss man wie ernst
muss man denn also nehmen man muss das
ernst nehmen vielleicht gibt es
irgendein Szenario von dem
probeatomschlag irgendwo in der Ostsee
ich weiß das nicht ich habe keine Ahnung
aber was ich sehe ist wenn sie mal die
Live Karte aufrufen Google wo die
Kriegsschiffe alle sind die die Welt so
hat das sind die meisten von
europäischen Küsten in der Nordsee in
der Ostsee es ist ziemlich eindeutig und
das heißt man rechnet auch damit dass es
eskaliert jetzt sage ich mal einen Punkt
wenn es wirklich dazu kommen sollte was
ich immer noch nicht glaube bisher waren
die Russen immer vorsichtig die einzigen
die hier Atome auf dem eingesetzt haben
waren die Amerikaner aber wenn es
wirklich dazu kommen sollte dann ist
Deutschland das Zentrum der
Auseinandersetzung nicht die Ukraine
dann sind wir dran und das waren meine
Geschichte
man wird ein Diktator wie Putin nicht
Stopp mit dem man sagt man weicht zurück
oder naja ein Land angreifen dann redet
man von diplomat man muss seine eigene
Stärke aufbauen
es gibt ein Ausgleich der Interessen und
wer das nicht mehr beherrscht und
kissenscher hat dort deutlich gesagt die
Amerikaner werden nicht kommen und
Soldaten nach Europa schicken ihr müsst
das selber hinkriegen wenn wir aber
nicht die Kapazitäten haben militärisch
von denen man ausgehen müsste um das zu
schaffen da muss man sich genau
überlegen wieder Interessensausgleich
aussieht die Russen werden am 15
September gesehen die Russen werden mit
Iran China Indien den arabischen Ländern
im Persischen Golf Saudi-Arabien
wahrscheinlich noch mit Brasilien mal
sehen wie die Wahl ausgeht jetzt in
Brasilien einen rohstoffkartell bilden
da ist Europa aber ganz blöd dran weil
nämlich die Energie und die Rohstoffe
Dinge sind die wir zwingend brauchen um
überhaupt noch in der Lage zu sein
exportfähig zu sein ich habe ihn vorhin
geschildert die Exportfähigkeit
manifestiert ungefähr 50% unserer
Ausgaben als Staat auch im Sozialbereich
überall wenn das nachher nicht mehr
erwirtschaftet werden kann aus diesen
genannten Gründen dann haben wir ja
sowas von einem Bürgerkrieg an der Hacke
ins in Europa es wird dramatisch das
muss man einfach mal zu Ende denken und
überlegen können wir das Stemmen einfach
nur wie junge Leute voranbrechen auch
super
hinsetzen und gucken ob sie die Sache
wenn das so einfach also das klingt ja
so als ob man nur mal reden müsste und
dann wäre alles gut also wirklich etwas
naiv und einfach das glaube ich nicht
also 58 naiv Spencer und die Frage ist
ob ich mein Sohn den Krieg schicken
Alter Schutz nicht Hallo
auf jeden Fall nicht so viel kann man
sagen danke schön
brauchen Sie gar nicht nein aber
vielleicht mal zurück zu der zu der
Angst weil ich glaube dass Angst um
etwas sehr diffuses ist was uns am Ende
bei der Entscheidungsfindung nicht hilft
sondern genau genommen lähmt und obwohl
ich die Angst grundsätzlich ja
nachvollziehen kann ich erlebe sie im
eigenen Familienkreis ich habe heute
eine Stunde bei der Mutter diskutiert
die ist 82 bald und die kann sich an den
Zweiten Weltkrieg noch aus eigener
Erinnerung erinnern und sie hört die
bombenschläge aus Dresden weil sie nicht
weiter von entfernt gewohnt hat insofern
die Angst muss man total ernst nehmen
aber man muss auch schauen wie
realistisch ist das und ich wir haben
alle ein bisschen geschmunzelt weil
Putin Satz vorhin das ist kein Bluff
also da kann man natürlich so oder so
darüber denken tatsächlich glaube ich
dass es relativ unwahrscheinlich ist
wenn sie mich jetzt naiv damit kann ich
leben ich halte es für relativ
unwahrscheinlich das Putin das tun wird
und ich glaube dass die Antwort der
Amerikaner bei aller Kritik die man
sonst an ihnen haben kann richtig was zu
sagen sollten die Russen das tun
nutzen amerikanische Antwort geben das
will keiner von uns da sind wir uns
glaube ich alle einig aber das was schon
viel zu lange passiert ist in diesem
Konflikt war dass bei den Europäern
gerade bei uns Deutschen nicht ganz klar
war wo wir lange Zeit gestanden haben
bemerken sie Kriegslust da sind sie
jetzt anderer Mann aber Frau Herrmann
kriegsministerin hat seine
Außenministerin würden sie damit also
ich hatte Frau bärbox für nicht sehr
mutig und das heißt diplomatisch
formuliert sie äußerten immer nur dann
Kritik wenn sie im Windschatten anderer
tun kann als Nancy Pelosi nach Taiwan
gereist ist war
persönlich
besonders fähig für das Amt dass sie
bekleidet und so wie sie jetzt nicht den
Mund aufmacht um Iran die Frauenrechte
zu verteidigen macht den anderen Stellen
auch nicht die Mund auf und es ist
ziemlich billig die Rosen zu kritisieren
wenn
die blicken und die Dellen und die
Amerikaner letztlich den Krieg für uns
dort führen wenn man die wenigen Waffen
rausnimmt die Deutschland dann doch
liefert also ich halte Frau bärbock an
der Stelle für nicht wirklich
zielführend und ich glaube nicht dass es
hilft die sich mit la Prof trifft weil
da hat vorher haben wir noch völlig
recht wir sind gar kein Gesprächspartner
für die Russen den nimmt sie doch zu
Recht nicht ernst das heißt es
verhandeln nur die Großmächte am Ende
auf Augenhöhe also müsste beiden Händen
ich glaube dass militärische eine ganze
Menge passieren muss und da müssen die
westeuropäischen Kräfte und die
Amerikaner zusammenhalten dieser
Konflikt wird dass es meine persönliche
Meinung militärisch entschieden und wenn
die Russen in eine Lage kommt in der sie
am Ende wirklich verhandeln müssen denn
wenn sie es tun insofern ergänze ich die
Amerikaner haben sicherlich kein
Interesse aber die Russen haben sich
derzeit auch nicht
Russland darf nur auf keinen Fall
gewinnen Russland muss diesen Krieg
verlieren weil wir haben ja wir haben
eben wir haben
genau was mir was mir wirklich jetzt
hier fehlt in der Diskussion da finden
wirklich ja schlimmste Verbrechen statt
Vergewaltigung der Putin attackiert
Krankenhäuser
Zivilisten also furchtbare Verbrechen
und da kann man doch nicht einfach
hinsehen und sagen aber was wir
behandeln diplomatische Lösung da
braucht es doch eine entschlossene
Antwort
für Sie gewinnen in dem Fall also aus
meiner Sicht muss Putin und müssen die
russischen Truppen komplett aus der
Ukraine raus also das beinhaltet auch
natürlich den Don Bass und beinhaltet
auch die Krim putinadia 2014 angefangen
mit den ersten Angriffen auf die Ukraine
auf ein souverän Staat und das können
wir das kann der Westen das kann
eigentlich jede Demokratie eigentlich
jeder souveräne Land in der Welt nicht
hinnehmen und da brauchst eine
entschlossene Antwort und es gibt so
viele schreckliche Ereignisse die dort
stattfinden also da können wir nicht
sagen na ja genau aber das wurde
überhaupt nicht thematisiert und
deswegen finde ich muss es auch eine
entschlossene Antwort geben und wir
können auch nicht sagen wir reden mal so
ein bisschen über
schicken oder wie weit würden Sie gehen
für den Sieg in der Ukraine wir haben
jetzt ja gesagt wir wollen nicht selber
Kriegspartei werden ich halte aber
Waffenlieferungen für absolut notwendig
auch dass da die Ampelkoalition viel
mehr macht also Panzer müssen unbedingt
geliefert werden
im Moment geht es ja auch in die
richtige Richtung also die Ukraine
gewinnt ja Land zurück und da passiert
ja etwas was wir selber wahrscheinlich
vor einigen Monaten gar nicht gedacht
hätten und deswegen der entschlossene
Anfang ich will jetzt doch die die muss
es geben und die kann es auch geben das
zeigt dass entschlossen handeln von
vielen anderen Ländern also ich glaube
dass dieser Gedanke die gesamte
ukrainische das gesamte ukrainische
Gebiet muss auf jeden Fall von Russen
von der russischen Armee und von Putin
befreit werden ist ein gefährlicher
Gedanke weil in diesem gewinnen wollen
von Putin steckt ja auch etwas von einem
nationalen Stolz drin und ich glaube
dass der Sieger das wäre in ihrem
Planspiel ja die Ukraine und der Westen
sehr darauf Acht geben muss dass er den
Verlierer nicht zu sehr demütigt wir
haben da ja selber
historisch zwei Erfahrungen nämlich eine
nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg wo es
geschehen ist und eine nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg wo es sozusagen viel Kritik
geben kann aber doch besser gelaufen ist
und das bedeutet man muss ja erstmal
aber Diktator
nein aber man muss ja man muss ja mit
den Menschen die in dem die die
sozusagen in dem Besiegten Land das
fällt mir schon schwer bei Russland
überhaupt zu sagen weil man sich nicht
vorstellen kann dass dieser Gigant dass
dieser Gigant überhaupt verlieren kann
aber wir sind in ihrem Denken Muster
dann würde ich dann wieder als Diplomat
sehr darauf achten dass man den nicht
der am Boden liegt auch noch demütigt
und lächerlich macht weil am Ende muss
man ja mit ihm oder seine Nachfolgern
die übrigens zur gleichen Nation gehören
und zum gleichen Schlager sind sprechen
können und mit gedemütigten zu sprechen
und ihnen etwas aufzuzwingen ist für die
Zeit danach ganz geschweige gibt dass
man das wahrscheinlich mit Russland
sowieso nicht kann irgendwas aufzwingen
ist für die Zeit danach ein gefährliches
Denkmuster da würde ich aus unserer
Geschichte lernen
nach einer ganz kurzen Unterbrechung
weiter es bleibt spannend bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfe
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jörg ist wir
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grünen roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die
rettungsweltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe meinen
Beifall meine lache immer bekommen wer
kümmert sich darum niemand bitte
ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch
darüber sprechen dass es einfach nicht
fair ist und nicht richtig wo ist die
Aufgabe von Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
mit der These von Klaus Strunz heute
Abend
ja mich haben die Bilder beeindruckt und
ich hatte sozusagen einen schon mal
gesehen ein DejaVu von Flüchtlingen die
in Dresden ankommen von immer mehr
Flüchtlingen die in Deutschland ankommen
von immer mehr Flüchtlingen die die
Balkanroute nutzen um auch in Österreich
anzukommen um in Bayern anzukommen es
sind jetzt schon wieder zahlen die fatal
an die erste Phase von dem erinnern was
wir als 2015 im Kopf haben und das
besorgt mich neben dem ganzen
Kriegsgeschehen über das war auch hier
diskutiert haben schon sehr weil ich
glaube wenn wir das als Gesellschaft und
als Politik komplett übersehen oder wie
es bei dem Thema Zuwanderung unsere
unser Fable ist in Deutschland es zu
tabuisieren wenn wir also nicht darüber
sprechen dass jetzt schon wieder
tausende kommen es ist die Rede davon
dass in diesem Jahr womöglich 200.000
Menschen über die Balkanroute nach
Deutschland kommen können die ja dann in
unserem Sozialsystem sozusagen ihre
Zukunft finden also in die Sozialkassen
ändern dann gibt es einen ganz brutalen
Unterschied zwischen 2015 war schon
schlimm genug war und heute heute ist es
ein anderes Deutschland die Vorstellung
dass
Rentnerinnen und Rentner zu Hause
frieren dass Familien die über zwei
kleinere Einkommen verfügen sich ihre
Stromrechnungen nicht mehr leisten
können dass wir aber Flüchtlingsheime
heizen in denen illegal Eingewanderte
Menschen sitzen die in Deutschland
nichts zu suchen haben weil sie kein
Asylrecht haben ist für mich das
Zündhölzchen an einer Lunte von sozialem
Sprengstoff von Unbekannten Ausmaß und
deshalb ist meine Forderung an die
Politik hinzugucken es ist meine
Forderung an die Medien hinzugehen wenn
man nämlich hingeht sieht man es sind
wieder jüngere Männer viele jüngere
Männer und schon muss man sagen das wird
die Kriminalstatistik betreffen das wird
unsere Sozialkassen betreffen ich habe
noch mal nachgeguckt ungefähr 20
Milliarden Euro kostet das asylgeben in
Deutschland unseren Staat also uns ihr
und mein Geld
das alles ist so toxisch so giftig so
gefährlich in dieser Debatte ein lautes
auch das noch dass ich mir sagen mache
dass hier tatsächlich etwas
auseinanderdriften kann an die Ränder
was man sich in dieser Weise gar nicht
vorstellen konnte Frau Petri wenn die
Flüchtlingsströme so weitergehen ist
die 21 Prozent
ich folge Klaus Strunz insoweit dass ich
sage in der Tat die Balkanroute wieder
als flüchtlingsroute aus Mittleren Osten
wir hören es auf Afghanistan sich
weiterhin viele Menschen aus dem Weg
machen aus anderen arabischen Ländern
das ist in der Tat die Fortsetzung von
2015 und wir haben natürlich immer so
ein bisschen bei der medialen
Betrachtung das Problem
das News die eigentlich News sind als
solche gar nicht mehr erkannt werden
weil wir die Bilder schon so oft gesehen
haben und Bilder die wir oft gesehen
haben blenden wir als Menschen einfach
aus weil wir sie vergessen wollen weil
wir sie über sind weil wir gesättigt
sind man muss davon unterscheiden dass
halte ich auch für wichtig das Thema
Ukraine Flüchtlinge und je nachdem wie
lange dieser Krieg noch dauert denn Herr
bloss ihre Vision dass ich das ist
schnell vorbei sein muss falls ja
wünschenswert wäre ist unter Umständen
gar nicht realistisch auch wenn ihr das
reingeht
gesagt gute und schlechte Flüchtlinge
die aus der Ukraine sind die guten die
woanders herkommen sind die schlechten
ja es gibt flüchtlings- und illegale
Migranten ich habe ja als ich aktiv war
darum gekämpft dass wir wirklich
politisch anfangen zwischen Menschen zu
differenzieren die tatsächlich nur für
eine Übergangszeit in Deutschland
Zuflucht brauchen und die die einfach
illegal in unsere Sozialsysteme
einwandern das ist politisch immer
bekämpft worden auch gerade von von den
Grünen und von allen linken Parteien die
eine Kategorisierung nicht vornehmen
wollen und das bis heute nicht tun denn
wir wissen ja auch dass selbst über die
Ukraine Menschen nach Deutschland
gekommen sind die keine Ukrainer waren
die aber schnell ukrainischen Pass
bekommen konnten insofern sehe ich auf
der einen Seite das was sie auch sehen
an der Strunz dass die Entwicklung in
der Tat auf ein anderes Europa auch
trifft auf ein Europa das langsam keine
Kapazitäten mehr hat also wir drohen
auch sozialtechnisch Stück für Stück auf
einen Stand abzurutschen indem wir nicht
mehr helfen können da ist doch Luft nach
unten aber die Frage ist ja wollen wir
diesen Weg weiter beschreiten aber auch
die Notwendigkeit zu sagen Flüchtlinge
aus dem Ukraine Krieg die müssen anders
behandelt werden da muss differenziert
werden und ich dann vielleicht noch eins
mir ist ganz wichtig ich mache das nicht
den Menschen die auf der
also oder richtig also wenn ich hören
würde irgendwo auf der Welt dass es ein
Start gibt ein Land gibt wo man nur drin
sein muss dann muss man nie mehr weg man
kommt auch nie mehr weg und hat mehr
Geld als die Menschen in dem Land die
Arbeiten gehen da würde ich ja alles
packen und bloß hin also ich mache
keinen vornehmer ich mache den Vorwurf
der Dämlichkeit derer die damit
riskieren dass all das was uns wichtig
ist er verloren geht und ich fordere
wirklich alle auf dass auch als eine Art
Verteidigung zu sehen eines Systems dass
wir gut und richtig finden denn wenn
dieses System kollabiert es ist weg
die Frage geht sogar an sie aber ein
Gedanke dazu noch es gibt ja auch
studienstatistiken die sagen dass wir
400.000 Einwanderer eigentlich pro Jahr
brauchen als Land als Deutschland
angebracht und Zuwanderung die Wahrheit
ist andere natürlich jetzt die Frage an
Sie ist Deutschland vielleicht einfach
zu blöd für die Integration also ich
glaube man muss tatsächlich da sehr
stark unterscheiden weil auf der einen
Seite
illegale Migration muss gestoppt werden
also das ist das volle Zustimmung anders
zu unterstellen aber andere
ein Programm also illegale Migration
muss klar gestoppt werden über einige
Folgen und Auswirkungen haben wir eben
gesprochen trotzdem darf man einen Punkt
auch nicht ausblenden nämlich dass wir
angesichts der immer älter werdenden
Bevölkerung natürlich auch Zuwanderung
brauchen wir brauchen nur die richtigen
in Deutschland also die Fachkräfte wir
brauchen mit wir haben mittlerweile ein
Arbeitskräftemangel also es sieht man ja
häufig wenn man vor Restaurant steht vor
Bar steht vor im Friseursalon steht ne
da steht dann entweder Mitarbeiter
gesucht oder sogar manchmal heute
geschlossen wegen Personalmangel und wir
brauchen deswegen die richtigen Leute
und das ist eine nicht ganz so einfache
Aufgabe weil wir natürlich gesetzlich
erschaffen müssen dazu differenzieren
und zu sagen wir brauchen beispielsweise
ein Punktesystem und gewisse Standards
dass die richtigen zu uns kommen können
die wir dringend benötigen auf der
anderen Seite müssen wir aber auch
sozusagen diejenigen die einfach nur in
die Sozialsysteme einwandern wollen
Ideen da müssen wir ein Stoppschild auch
aber wir haben doch schon längst die Tür
zugeschlagen für richtige Fachkräfte ich
sehe es ja Mittelstand jeden Tag in
meiner Arbeit beim beim
mittelstandsverband wir diskutieren die
Fachkräfte Situation dann ist es klar
man braucht da wirklich sehr gut
ausgebildete Leute der Mittelstand ist
keine fließbandboote wo ein riesenfabrik
ist so alles wieder Fließband da musst
du was können sonst brauchst du da gar
nicht anfangen so und jetzt ist der Witz
aber dass Leute die was können auch
rechnen können und die können natürlich
rechnen dass sie hier in dem Land eine
Menge arbeiten uns alte deutschen unsere
alten deutschen bezahlen und dann selber
nichts haben werden deswegen gehen die
in Länder wo die mehr für sich haben an
ihrem Geld es ist der erste
das reicht eben nicht sie sagen also die
guten kommen gar nicht mehr Deutschland
ist kein Zuwanderungsland der ersten
Klasse mehr für ausgebildete Fachkräfte
abwanderungsland wir haben
netto-fachkräfte Verluste so und
deswegen glaube ich dass man in der
ganzen Gesetzgebung neu aufbauen muss in
der Sozialgesetzgebung das kam ja heute
schon jetzt in der eingangsthese ist es
dringend notwendig zu überlegen dass man
zumindest Einzahl dauern irgendwas in
der Arten festlegen muss dass auch nicht
wieder in diesen Bezug kommt und wir
haben eine skandinavischen Ländern
gesehen die haben das alle durch
exerziert Dänemark Schwedt andere
Norwegen ist ganz klar die haben gesagt
natürlich muss man Menschen in Not
helfen die kriegen auch was zu essen und
werden warm untergebracht das ist heute
schon viel und das muss reichen und das
ist eben nicht so dass man hier einfach
jahrelang mit zwei drei Frauen und zehn
Kindern im Haus leben kann und andere
Ehepaare deutsche Ehepaare verzichten
aufs zweite Kind weil sie sich nicht
leisten können das geht nicht gehört
heute der Schlusswort wir sind am Ende
der Sendung angekommen morgen haben
sollten Sie aber auch einschalten dann
sitzen hier nämlich Frau Wagenknecht und
auch Herr anderer bis morgen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]